Houston
problem
the ship is experiencing engine
malfunction
hyperdrive functioning
something's wrong
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you crashed on an alien planet
you've traveled thousands of light years
through Interstellar star systems and
now you're stranded on a planet you know
nothing about
as long as you've got oxygen water and
food aboard your spaceship
you should stay inside and figure out
what you've got going on around you
but your supplies wouldn't last forever
so the clock would be ticking
now you didn't crash on an alien world
just to die your mission is to collect
any information you can on this planet
and try to survive in the process
before you even got a glimpse of your
surroundings there's one thing you'd
need to figure out
it's the gravity of the planet you
landed on
sure it could be just like back home but
the chances of that would be pretty low
realistically this world's gravity would
be something you'd need to get used to
it could be lower than on Earth and
you'd feel lighter over time it would
make your vision blurred your muscles
shrink and your back hurt a lot
but if it was stronger than on Earth
well you'd feel heavier and maybe it
would even be strong enough to keep you
pinned to the ground or even break your
bones
next you need to find out what kind of
star this alien planet is orbiting and
where in the star system it's positioned
there's a high chance that you'd be on
an exoplanet orbiting the most common
type of star in the universe a red dwarf
many of the 4 000 exoplanets we've
discovered orbit these
but red dwarfs are smaller and cooler
than our own Sun so the planet you've
landed on would have to orbit its star
at a distance much closer than Earth
orbits the Sun at least if you wanted it
to be habitable with liquid water on the
surface
but being this close could result in a
harsh environment
if the star was only a few billion years
old you'd need ways to protect yourself
from the high energy blasts of
ultraviolet and x-ray radiation
if you couldn't Shield yourself you'd
need to seek shelter Underground
otherwise you'd suffer from long-term
radiation exposure
this would cause cataracts make you
sterile and greatly increase your risk
of cancer
while you're observing the star you'd
need to take note of whether there's a
sunrise and sunset or is it that the Sun
never seems to move in the sky
this would be another danger of being so
close to its star your new home planet
could be tidally locked
this means that one side of the world
would always experience daylight and the
other side would always be shrouded in
darkness
and it wouldn't just be a matter of
Light Dark it would also mean that one
side would be scorching hot and the
other would be freezing cold
you'd be on a planet caught between two
extremes and your best bet for surviving
would be to head toward the Terminator
line
this would be the thin strip of land
between the day side and the night side
here you'd have a Goldilocks situation
where it's not too hot and not too cold
but you'd also have the incredible treat
of never-ending Dusk and Dawn
the next thing you'd want to assess is
whether you'd have an atmosphere that
you could breathe
just because it's in the habitable zone
wouldn't mean it's habitable for you
you'd need oxygen
lucky for you astronomers found that
exoplanets with breathable air are more
common than you might think
but keep your oxygen tank close by as
you experiment with breathing out there
as an astronaut you've already been EX
hardships that come with the job like
living with different levels of gravity
various magnetic fields and of course
psychological stress
but landing on an alien planet you'd
have a few more things to add to the
list if you had a weakened immune system
you could be vulnerable to infection
from microorganisms we've never seen
before that would make you patient zero
on a planet where you'd be the closest
thing to a doctor
researchers suggest that all kinds of
lethal bacteria or viruses could survive
in the extremely harsh conditions of
space
so you'd need to take precautions and
not even just for your own protection
but for the possible life on this alien
planet
you'd be carrying who knows how many
pathogens and microorganisms from back
on Earth
these could kill or wipe out organisms
that you haven't even detected yet
speaking of which could there be life on
this planet you've crashed into
well if you wanted to find out your best
bet would be to head to the nearest
source of water
don't get overly excited just yet the
most likely possibility is that you'd
only discover
microorganisms but that wouldn't
completely rule out the chances that
intelligent life could be waiting for
you around any corner
if you did make first contact with an
intelligent life form the first thing
you'd have to do would be to try
communicating with it after all you
wouldn't want to make the most amazing
Discovery in human history only for them
to kill you out of fear or aggression
you could try using linkos a Dutch
mathematician invented this language in
the 1960s and he meant it for one
purpose only to speak with aliens
you'd start slow and develop the
language further so both you and the
aliens can understand
first you'd need to make sure that they
grasp the concept of numbers and then
you'd move on to complex Concepts like
love or death
but the chances would be higher that you
would land on a planet with seemingly no
intelligent life
you'd be all alone
no humans or aliens to talk to
spending thousands of hours in total
isolation you could eventually suffer
from hallucinations and hear voices in
your head this would be your new reality
but all of this wouldn't change the fact
that you want to survive
you'd have to keep your wits about you
and put any planetary resources you can
find to use
you might not be back home for a while
and in the meantime you'd still have to
eat if there were any alien life forms
walking past you you might start looking
at them like their cartoon roast
chickens
ah imagine eating an alien well
that's a story
for another
[Music]